vielleicht spreche ich gerade ein Thema
die sie nicht so beliebt und nicht gerne
hören wollen es geht eigentlich um den
politischen Islam und den Islamismus vor
allem kurz bevor wir angefangen Fußball
zu gucken in Katar ist nicht nur
gefährlich und problematisch weil sie
8000 Menschen das Leben gekostet hat
beim Baum von Stadien sondern vor allem
weil sie weltweit die islamistische
Strukturen finanzieren auch hier in
Deutschland auch hier in Europa sie
verbreiten Hass sie verbreiten
Antisemitismus sie verbreiten eine Islam
der nicht nur eine Weltreligion ist
sondern vor allem eine politische Macht
haben will und wir gehen damit völlig
naiv wir wollen damit nicht hören unsere
Politiker wollen sich damit nicht
beschäftigen schauen Sie nach Iran wie
mutig die Frauen auf der Straße gehen
was sie zeigen und was machen wir wir
lassen eine Außenposten des iranischen
Regime als Partner von den Stadt Hamburg
gelten
islamischer Zentrum Hamburg ist eine
Außenposten des politischen Islam und
war und wir wollen das nicht mehr
irgendwie wahrnehmen und diejenigen die
irgendwie davon warnen sind mittlerweile
Krawallmacher Islamhasser Islam Feinden
Rassisten es trifft mich ich lebe seit
Jahren unter Personenschutz und ich
kriege nicht genug Unterstützung von dem
Politiker die eigentlich das Thema nicht
mehr hören wollen es gibt ja einen Punkt
den viele sagen der Glaube an den
reformierten Islam ist das eine
Möglichkeit dass sie sich vielleicht in
Zukunft bessern könnte weißt du
jahrelang habe ich geglaubt auch alles
Einwanderer dass wenn ein reformierter
Islam wenn ein Islam der mit Demokratie
und Menschenrechte irgendwann entstehen
wird dann wird aus Europa entstehen
aber mittlerweile glaube genau also die
europäische Muslime die hier
sozialisiert sind die mit Demokratie und
Menschen groß geworden sind das sind
diejenigen die das nach vorne bringen
wollen mittlerweile liberale Moschee in
Berlin genau ja ein Beispiel der
eigentlich von Politik aber auch leider
von vielen Muslima gekämpft werden und
genau
wie anderen auch ich schätze ihre Arbeit
sehr aber mittlerweile glaube ich dass
wenn der Reformbewegung kommen soll dann
wird sie aus den Nahen Osten kommen die
iranische Frauen zeigen uns gerade wie
es in Europa geht und warum weil wir die
falschen hofieren weil wir nicht mehr
mit seran attisch oder mit Ahmad man so
zusammenarbeiten wollen sondern mit
DITIB mit ech und mit anderen und das
tut die Politik in allen möglichen
Parteien ob das in Berlin ob das in
warum macht die Politik das weil sie
unbedingt diese Religion die kirchliche
Strukturen aufzwingen wollen sie wollen
Ansprechpartner und diese anspre Partner
sind da das sind die Tipps das ist ech
das ist mir ligurisch Organisation die
Moscheen haben und man sagt ja sie
vertrennen die Muslime hat deshalb
nehmen wir sie machen mit den
Islamkonferenz geben vor der Gelder das
ist unglaublich LCH kriegt Gelder um
derartikalisierungsarbeit zu machen
bitte kriegt Geld da um
Integrationsarbeit zu betreiben
diejenigen die ihnen Moschee Werte
vermitteln die mit dem Grundgesetz nicht
vereinbart sind kriegen vor der Gelder
und andere nicht und das ist absolut
dann würde ich gerne einmal wir haben
jetzt zwei Politiker
Bundestagsabgeordnete sitzen einmal CDU
am FDP Herren ist die Politik der
vielleicht zu naiv oder die Parteien
also es ist ein bisschen
recht
wir werden den Islam nicht abschaffen
und wir sollten ihn auch nicht versuchen
abzuschaffen sind eine Milliarde
Menschen es hat gar keinen Sinn zweitens
natürlich nicht aus der Diaspora kommt
die Reform sondern immer aus dem Zentrum
und das können wir nur hoffen dass wir
keine Muslime sind und da nicht leben
müssen das zu machen zum Beispiel
iranischen Frauen hoffen wir mal dass
das gut geht ich habe wo sie sorgen
da sind wir erstmal einer Meinung
aber haben sie auch das Gefühl das
Parallelgesellschaften schon entstehen
in Deutschland
ja also ich finde es ein bisschen sehr
weitgehend parallel gesagt aber es gibt
Zellen die ganz klar
verfassungsfeindlich sind wie das
islamische Zentrum in Hamburg die auch
kein Geld bekommen dürfen
wer ist die CDU eigentlich relativ klar
wenn wir gerade vor weiß ich nicht zwei
Monaten im Bundestag einen
entsprechenden Antrag eingereicht keine
Mehrheit bekommen
es ist also wir sind ein Staat der mit
den einzelnen Gruppen verhandelt wir
verhandeln mit den Gewerkschaften und
Arbeitgebern und dann versuchen wir da
ein Kompromiss zu machen ist auch eine
große Stärke von Deutschland und wir mit
den muslimenten
Ratlosigkeit also wenn wir
zusammenfassen will ist die Politik da
ratlos beim Problem sozusagen dieses
Phänomen gibt es sonst so in den
deutschen Staaten nicht wir verstehen
das schon als Problem so doof sind jetzt
auch meine Kollegen nicht oder so aber
die Einsatz erlaubt mir nur Einsatz weil
weil sie gesprochen haben das ist keine
Parallelgesellschaften in Deutschland
gibt ich bin der Meinung gibt es die
sind natürlich sehr begrenzt im
Vergleich zu Frankreich aber ich sage
Ihnen eins das sind keine Gesellschaft
haben wir französische Verhältnisse wenn
wir jetzt nicht anfangen zu agieren wenn
wir nicht anfangen diese Problem zu
behandeln und da tun wir viel zu wenig
dazu wir wollen was anders sehen wir
haben viele Krisen aber das ist auch
eine Krise die wir behandeln können das
ist auch eine und natürlich die Recht
der Vertrag mit DITIB ist falsch
wir brauchen mehr islamische Ausbildung
in Deutschland den Vertrag einmal
erklären oder sie auch hier ach manchmal
so den Vertrag was ist das finanziert
von der Türkei die die Tipp machen die
Ausbildung der muss in den Moscheen von
dem Geistlichen die da wieder arbeiten
also das was wir parallel gehen dass wir
das unterstützen also das ist aber weil
wir keine andere Wärme wir haben eben
nur im Kleinen gibt es aber nur in
kleinen Rudimenten alternative
Strukturen die wir dann lieber
finanzieren und der Staat kann immer nur
in Strukturen arbeiten in Deutschland
und nicht einzelne Person gehen ich
hatte das also ich war ja Justizsenator
und wir haben ja mehr deutlich größeren
Anteil Gläubiger Muslime als gläubiger
Christen in den Gefängnissen deswegen
haben die auch ein Rechtsanspruch und
Verfassungsanspruch auf Betreuung ja
jetzt finden Sie mal Leute die in den in
den in den Gefängnissen bereit sind
Psychologen nennt sich das aber das das
gibt ein Unterschied es gibt einen
Unterschied ob ich dann Muslime da
reinbringe die auch
verfassungskomfort ist oder ob ich einen
ein politischer islam-aktor der in
Israel sogar teilweise als Terror
Finanzierer Geld und das tut Berlin und
das ist
habe ich das geändert ich nee das ist
nicht gegen vielfältig von Herrn
Heilmann hier zu sagen wir sind da auch
ein Stück weit ratlos als Politik und
man muss da auf jeden Fall was anders
machen
sind ja möglich also
das IZH angesprochen hat der Bundestag
hat ja beschlossen dass wir iceta
rausnehmen das ist keine Gelder mehr
kriegen muss ist gestaltet sich wieder
mal schwer in Deutschland wieso alles
schwer ist in Deutschland aber also dass
das Thema haben wir tatsächlich aber wo
waren sie 10 Jahre Etch nicht
problematisch seit zwei Monaten die die
Politik reagiert nur weil die Bilder zu
stark Anfragen also ich will das seit
einem Jahr in der Regierung warum ist 17
Jahre gedauert hat fakt ist der
Bundestag hat jetzt beschlossen
punktierte Region Deutschland muss
Deutschland muss in die Imam Ausbildung
einsteigen ich sehe dazu keine
alternativ
auch bei den katholischen Kirche auch
bei den Lehrstunden da reden wir auch
mit ich bin grundsätzlich der Meinung
wir sollten starten Kirche trennen das
war ein anderes Thema aber wir müssen in
die äh immer Ausbildung einsteigen was
tatsächlich ein Problem ist wo es nur
wenig Ideen gibt es ist natürlich komoot
mit der christlichen Kirche zu sprechen
da hast du da den Papst der ist sowieso
der Chef von allen und dann hast du eine
klare Struktur wie die EKD funktioniert
ich gebe ihnen beide mein neues Buch der
wo ganz konkrete
beispielsendung heute an ihn an Sie
stellen also an Dich stellen wenn du
zuerst machen wir auch hier in der
Sendung du bist ja sehr skeptisch und
ein neues Buch heißt ja auch damit ist
es richtig wiedergebe Operation aller
ich muss es noch lesen wie sieht
Deutschland in 20 Jahren aus hier ist
jetzt auch eingeblendet das Buch aber
wie sieht denn Deutschland in 20 Jahren
aus die Politik ist ratlos aktuell aber
wie würdest du es einschätzen also ich
mache diese Arbeit weil ich optimistisch
bin auch wenn ich natürlich die Thesen
die Realität sage ich mal anders
aussieht ich glaube das hängt von uns ab
also wenn wir wirklich die Politiker
gewinnen können eine anderen Weg zu
gehen einfach weniger naiv zu sein und
konkret auch nach anderen Strukturen
suchen dann bin ich optimistisch dass
wir auch dieses Problem Herr werden am
Anfang hast du ja den Vergleich zu
Frankreich gezogen
da sind wir also noch nicht es gibt noch
Hoffnung es gibt zehn Jahre da hängt von
uns ab wir mussten jetzt anfangen
dagegen zu steuern in zehn Jahren da
können Sie das Speichern und in zehn
Jahren treffen wir uns wenn wir jetzt
nicht handeln haben wir französische
Verhältnisse und das macht mir große
Sorgen und es ist möglich absolut
was nehmen sie denn jetzt heute mit hier
bei Operation aller werden sie jetzt
sich da noch mehr engagieren dass das in
unser Land nicht passiert ich bin kein
Innenpolitiker bin auch kein
religionspolitikers wir reden ja von
Fachpolitikern aber ich nehme das als
Anstoß mit meinen Kollegen zu reden ob
wir da nicht mehr machen könnte